eh bien bon jour où nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec le carlito mcfly et le
grand gibier un maximum d'ambiance dans
ce studio la bienvenue les amis
aujourd'hui on est sur un jeu très
amusant c'est un jeu qui s'appelle use
your world
en gros on va avoir des séquences de
films des photos des articles de journal
tout ça et il y aura pas de sous titres
et ce sera à nous de légende et le truc
c'était clair c'est de la merde nickel
potasse ont le meilleur moyen de faire
comprendre le jaugeant d'animateur de
supermarché est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
alors c'est un film récent drame en
grèce entraînerait s'en fout ouest
anouilh qui passe pourquoi donc les amis
on a une minute trente pour chacun
trouver une phrase
à ce titre et c'est parti je vais pas je
n'ai pas je vais pas d'eau mais prend le
temps qu'il faut ok mais si j'ai tenté
un truc c'est pas très amusant mais
abonnez vous attend à la réversion ça
c'est la version d'accord ou alors un
mec d'entre nous qui est vraiment pas
drôle c'est toi donc ces autorités
c'est le seul mec
enfin spir il est génial oui oui on peut
faire une phase animateurs un peu nul et
ce n'est que le début le réentendre des
bonheurs iphone on a des gars mais ça
fait d'autres choses allaient y
affronter
j'ai rien j'ai rien je recommence à jack
manigat suis commercial sérieux bon
c'est horrible je vous souhaite se
concentrer que sur votre corps est ok on
y va quand on promo
[Musique]
les nouvelles épreuves
c'est un filon n'est pas les extraits
sont fous c'est assez dire là les mecs
fiable au fait ça avant avec joe black
tana en a plusieurs
ok j'ai mis un troquet je suis désolé je
suis je veux dire un truc ça et tout ce
qui va se passer après avoir regardé
mien sauce consulter mecs qui sont ma
place je me sens ok d'accord elles font
pipi l'ado ouais bah ouais y en a un qui
est attiré par ses passes à damas et
bien servir de terre a aussi donné quoi
vous devez vous y allez [ __ ] j'ai truc
j'en ai un génial ingénieur passé
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout ça fait mal
aux jambes assez malhonnête je les dis
bah bois vous me dites mais moi en tout
cas moi je suis chaud tient là son frère
moi j'ai pas d'hier sinon c'est très dur
on est donc là c'est dur c'est très dur
ok pas évident je suis passé par
plusieurs étapes dans des réflexions
dans ma tête
au début j'étais sur mon mois après j'ai
complètement grillé j'ai eu des doutes
mais est-ce que c'est pas humain d'avoir
des doutes on a des facultés nous les
humains c'est l'adaptation au contexte
environnant et les doutes mais j'ai pas
vu comme ça
c'était toi
carlito je te dire un truc c'est
tellement pas bien je pensais que
c'était bien des thèmes des coudes bien
[Rires]
waouh au [ __ ] de merde moi j'en ai
plein aux jaune et c'est très bien car
l'idole la merde alors mais c'est le
rôle de gitan
ils ont inversé la crainte de la
précarité
c'est simple ça fait quoi ça fait 15 ans
qu'on époque j'ai jamais vu cela il faut
être jamais oh la la il y arrive pas
alléger les pressions la pop est mort
mais quoi regarde pas c'est lui
on a ri et bien les amis c'est la fin de
cette vidéo en compagnie de karystos de
mcfly du grand cinéma comme ça plus si
calme c'est pas lui qui d'habitude
souscrivez à un abonnement à la chaîne
de mcfly carlito et aussi à la chaîne du
grand gibier sur 100 oui ils font
d'excellentes vidéo je vous invite
après le rayon charcuterie allez vous
abonner simplement regarder leurs vidéos
abonnez-vous également à la chaîne de
lucas voilà qui a besoin d abonnés il a
besoin de dix mille abonnés pour accéder
et puis vivez votre vie prenez soin de
vous n'oubliez pas qu'on sème tout ce
qu'on est en train carpediem pis
[Musique]
ça